[موسيقى]
اختتمت هنا في العاصمه الاوغنديه كمبالا
القمه التاسعه عش لمجموعه دول لعدم
الانحياز هذه القمه التي ناقشت العديد من
القضايا الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه والتوترات
السياسيه ولكن القضيه الفلسطينيه وحرب
اسرائيل على غزه هيمنت على مجريات هذه
القمه العديد من المتحدثين نددوا بهذه
الحرب ومنهم الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطوني جوتيريش الذي خاطب ختام فعاليات
هذه القمه وطالب بوقف فور انساني لاطلاق
النار في غزه وايضا السماح بايصال
المساعدات
الانسانيه رفض قبول حل الدولتين وحرمان
الشعب الفلسطيني من حقه في اقامه دولته
غير مقبول اسرائيل بالتاكيد تطيل امد هذا
الصراع والذي بات يمثل تهديدا للامن
والسلم العالميين ويزيد من حده استقطاب
ويدفع الى مزيد من التطرف في كل مكان حق
الفلسطينيين يجب ان يعترف به
الجميع هناك العديد من الرؤساء والممثلين
للمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه تحدثوا عن
هذه المساله وحرب غزه وضروره وقف هذه
الحرب المستمره على الفلسطينيين والدمار
الذي يشهد تشهده غزه والمعاناه التي
يعيشها
الفلسطينيون هذه القمه ايضا افردت مساحات
واسعه للقضايا والتوترات السياسيه حول
العديد من المنطقه سواء كان الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا وايضا اسيا العديد من الدول التي
تشهد توترات امنيه حوت هذه القمه اعلانات
سياسيه اعلان سياسي خاص بهذه التوترات
السياسيه وايضا اعلان خاص بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه داعي لوقف الحرب على غزه